c'est la saint valentin c'est que de
l'amour et j'ai envie de vous donner
d'amour ce soir tu nous en donne déjà de
losey qui vous permet à vos après
peut-être de faire ce que vous voulez de
moi des labours je n'ai pas vu le
premier à être concernées c'est je crois
que oui se sont plantés donc tu dois
trouver
on sait donc tué sept personnes ça fait
partie j'ai eu beaucoup de chance pour
trois ans j'ai fait mon spectacle un peu
partout en france et il y a des des
garçons et des jeunes filles qui sont
venus tout au long de cette tournée et
qui m'ont suivi qui sont venues des fois
dans des villes exprès et ça fait partie
de sa part comment mathilde évidemment
comme la meilleure amie de kanye qu'on a
eu tout à l'heure c'est la meilleure
amie kelly aussi c'est donc le plan de
maxime guennic maxime gagnais bien ma
fille mathilde et là ce soir
battus
[Applaudissements]
et franchement m at il été un cadeau
matines parce que tu es une des plus
grandes fans de jean luc est content
d'être sur ce plateau avec lui sur place
ce soir l'étoile a inculqué d'offres bah
oui j'ai vu au moins six fois en
spectacle et à chaque fois je fais des
photos avec les vins mais c'est très
touchant parce que mathilde comme comme
d'autres sur sont venus et c'est vrai
mais attendez en plus après des fois
dans le froid parce que la sortie des
des théâtres et donc merci merci et avec
l'hiver on peut trouver l'amour c'est
c'était l'hiver
[Applaudissements]
alors elle mathilde c'est ont préféré de
toutes les stars françaises
oui c'est vrai ah ouais à chaque fois je
le vois je dis que c'est un génie
bah ça moi même à chaque fois que je le
vois pas je me dis que c'est un génie ta
femme
c est ce qu a fait des jaloux sa famille
a passé un bon dîner à sa femme on y
femmes et five sa team qu'est ce qui te
rend tendon et loga temps de manger la
rose balti elle et elle est fan de jean
luc elle n'est pas amoureuse de lui ah
non il ya ces traits platonique bien sûr
non mais on sait que défend pas trop
c'est louche ne défend pas faites vous
un gros bisou et mathilde on est très
heureux qu elle attend la deuxième
cabine qui concerne tél et là ne vous
plantez pas sinon il ya le moyen de voir
ils savent écrire le prénom isabelle qui
est dans la cabine selon vous pour vous
un ami
alors oui à aucun moment là on vient
d'arriver
alors ça peut ben mon mari on est fâché
est ce que vous avez dit oui peut-être
venir pour la saint valentin
moi je viendrai pas là moi je reviendrai
quoi cette embrouille avec votre mari
parce que j'étais en retard en sortant
de l'émission hier donc il m'a dit
atteint d'intel intel intel est déjà
sorti j'ai décidé de me parler me
débrouille mais moi j'attends nom et
donc je lui ai dit arrête moi au feu je
peux prendre un taxi et c'est ce que
j'ai fait non non en revanche nous taxer
non c'est vrai ça va s'arranger grave
bah oui ça s'arrangera que week-end à
lausanne à quotas ce week-end et c'est
reparti est-ce qu'il est de ce siècle
alors isabelle est ce que vous vous
rappelez de votre premier amour et mon
premier amour mais vous l'avez dit le
tout doit être là est-ce que vous
rappelle comment il s'appelle gilles
gaston non mais ils sont bien pensés pas
il ya eu un gilles ya eu 1 c'était y'a
combien de temps honoré abdelhadi
c'était sous rené coty alors alors vous
allez me l'apprendre
le jeune sétois dida extension vient pas
il s'appelait mais je sais pas vous
triez en avant que j'adorais quand
j'étais quand j'avais 12-13 ans mais
joël mais il n'a jamais su joël il n'a
jamais su que je l'aimé beaucoup
joël joël c'était où c'était dans le
mythe dans le sud
pascoe joël dans le sud considéré loi il
est en vacances ou s'ils avaient ils
avaient qu'à l'âge
à l'époque on va se dire en avoir 12 13
il vient d'avoir 15 16
oui mais non non non non et là ce soir
non pas regarder alors joël joël joël
s'il vous plaît joël
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on est la lourdeur de la production sa
voix de joël parfaitement bien vous
rappelez des appels l'oublier imagine qu
est ce qui vous fait ce qui lui plaît
qu'est ce qu'une cédé 6 me fait rire oui
ah oui c'est comme un vrai prénom michel
michel celle ses tresses et intemporel
michel layaz quand il vous plaît ou pas
michel lis les paroles et bouali lui
très bien merci
j'étais ambulatoire aussi d'ailleurs car
finalement je vais garder le dis en
mobylette alors parce que à l'avenir ça
a même plus utile et ça c'est vraiment
ça c'est vraiment leur lourdeur ils me
disent tu vas voir on a retrouvé
j'écoute une bulle dos qui sont lourds
sans détour c'est pas possible cette
lourdeur la troisième cabine
ah c'est vrai à elle concerne un garçon
il s'agit d'eux c'est une cabine un peu
particulière puisque malheureusement
elle n'est pas là les mecs mais est ce
que le bond est la gagne l'abbé botte de
partout la personne va être au téléphone
et on va voir si vous allez à riz arrivé
à reconnaître la voix à benjamin
franchement là c'est du vrai et ça vous
faire très plaisir
un téléphone j'ai décroché un beau
cadeau non mais on s'en fou s'était pour
le dos à la gueule on va voir si vous
arrivez à reconnaître la voix est ce que
la personne au téléphone peut dire
quelques mois dans jamin bonsoir on va
voir jacques du cuivre quoi c'est qui
bien sûr c'est lucie brossette quoi
c'est qu'ils ont dû suivre cette cki
lucie brossette c'était mon premier
grand amour à l'école alsacienne et vous
êtes décalage on était petit on était en
c'était pendant le voyage de exavier
calage moi j'ai pas 12 ans entre gras
vous pouviez pas vous marier à l'époque
on n'a pas reconnu la voix c'était là
c'était la plus jolie de l'école et on
apprenait on est parti à rome ensemble
parce qu'on a des photos et elle est
toujours jolie lucy est toujours valu si
vous êtes le premier amour de benjamin
bah oui apparemment j'en suis très
flatté c'est faut qu'il ait reconnu la
vente mais parce qu'enfin la cab et vous
l'avez revues ou pas non je n'ai jamais
revu on a échangé vaguement sur facebook
je croyais à quelques et quand j'ai
reconnu la voix qu'elle avait alors la
voix la voix est exactement la même
parce qu'elle était très grande elle
faisait le faisait déjà m 80 quelque
chose comme ça arrêter quoi à 12 ans là
mais bon l amf à l'arrivée à l'école
d'étoilés vous de du carré magique
l'avait allaité elle était très elle
était allée à bâtir leur côté ces mois
d'été chien oui voilà vaches et donc
c'est vous la wii ah oui ça oui j'ai pas
nouvelle déjà ah oui là c'est un doigt à
l'époque est dieu bénisse ouais ouais
bah et roger dakiche à la choucrouterie
vraiment très très bon et on sait jamais
revu mais sait on était très proches ont
elles valaient bien
l'uci est ce que vous étiez très
amoureuse de benjamin bons mots et mais
non avec evidon en fait moi je pense que
c'est avant 12 ans bref on devait être
que la fin kg n en avait on en était
déjà ainsi viennent donc jeté verduzan
est en fête avec des trucs assez évident
et on est cool et et elle est très belle
année pour moi lui c est vraiment envie
de le revoir
évidemment oui jean oui oui est-ce que
vous pouvez venir le voir semaine
prochaine est ce que la femme de ben
jawad accorde un petit texto quand même
envie de le voir la semaine prochaine
bien sûr j'adore la semaine prochaine
mais malheureusement ça va être
compliqué moi je suis quand même un peu
loin je suis dans le sud de l'andalousie
donc pas réussi
oui assez ri et j'ai une fille et une
petite fille de 7 ans d'accord mais il
adore les enfants y organisant sa carte
scolaire
[Applaudissements]
ça va passer et bat lucie en tout cas
merci d'avoir été avec nous ça fait un
petit bond et intime ça va user
oui je ne vois pas les missions j'espère
qu'on n'attend pas 35 ans c'est une
cabine de la boule cabine pour [ __ ] la
merde pouvoir récupérer ton téléphone
puisque tu au téléphone on sort on va
s'appeler webcams et vous quand même
qu'on a peu nombreux mais notre avec
plaisir alors par contre si la famille
veut passer des vacances gratuites
merci
[Applaudissements]
c'est un l'andalousie j'ai l'impression
que l'uci et andalousie j'aimerais que
c'est la belle andalouse
non mais c'est vrai qu'il va s'y mettre
attention j'ai pas envie de vous la
voyez pas ce que je ne veux pas
d'histoires que votre nom prénom numéro
5 ça va il est quoi on sait déjà le
prénom d'un numéro c crosser
merci est très sympa ce maquillage
justement dans la cabine pour ya
quelqu'un pour vous jean-michel parce
que j'ai vu il ya quelqu'un pour vos
jours me touche pas mal jean michel est
ce que vous connaissez la personne qui
est dans la cabine on va donc des formes
et la voix vous à essayer de trouver qui
s'apprête à son idée reconnaît peindre
c'est vrai allez aller allons-y allô
allô allô allô c'est quelqu'un qui a
inspiré de l'hélium appareils allez-y
pas parler oui bonjour inconnu mystère
bonsoir l'invité mystère a connu plein
air j'ai un texto de la femme de ben
jawad merci beaucoup
les serrures sont changés déjà bonjour
mademoiselle bas j'en ai un autre je
dîne d'or j'arrive motion un autre je
dîne avec toi
on sait qu'on se connaît ouais bah oui
oui a longtemps ou pas longtemps c'est à
dire hier avant-hier
non mais vous vous êtes affecté ce je
vous laisse avec une jeune fille ivre ou
avant-hier challenge alger des
assistants des choses comme ça mais j'ai
dit la vérité il faut préciser lorsque
ça bouge beaucoup l'avaient été avec une
jeune femme ya pas longtemps mais t'en
souviens visiblement oui visiblement oui
j'ai dit la vérité
ben il ya quelqu'un là dans les boîtes
dans des habits avant-hier on est quinze
jours alors qui c'est beau c'est une
machine à ana ana alors alors gg une
lettre ou pas déjà là je sais pas elle
était avec vous l'a dit les choses
arrivent a forcé plusieurs chutes dans
la merde combien de temps comme chose
sarenza com ses ébats c est non c'est
pas ça je suis troublée avec la voir
[Musique]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
les séries ainsi alors je vous dis donc
les parlementaires à 21h jobim vous
pouvez annuler la bise de l'amour ça
veut dire qu'elle m'aime pas vous n'êtes
pas des liqueurs et nommé parce que si
ça vous met dans l'embarras
oui oui oui j'y suis déjà non non j'ai
ma jeu non je prends pas de joker avant
je je je valide je prends la caméra
kamin gc ca rien ne peut prendre la
cabine au salaire du mois la personne
qui est derrière la cabine
c'est quelqu'un qui vous a dit quelque
chose un jour regarder de jeanine et 60
michel avec moi tu veux si tu es avec
moi mais tu oublies tout et autres
représentantes
apparemment elle a le même hortefeux
[Rires]
jean mich est un petit cul sexy
[Applaudissements]
ça y est la poire d'à côté
viens vous dire les animals vous qui
vous a le droit je l'adoré
garcia luna
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
elle a droit
[Applaudissements]
janine saine une fin on adore qui
devenait dan in vraiment tu sais comme
je t'aime et je sais que toute l'équipe
de tpm pays c'est un peu comme tafalla
et tu sais que pour nous tu compte
beaucoup
vraiment tu sais comme je t'aime mais
comme je suis près de toi je laisse ma
place je pense que j'ai pas de noms mais
on aime très fort jeanine allez allez
rester après le dvd parce que jeanine
tas d'or est vous l'avez votre sujet de
la douane tubize où on a souvent discuté
ensemble à ce changement on ce qu'il
fallait lâcher allez allez tous les deux
des canisites à tort monsieur j'adore
jany c'est une rigolade en plus on peut
découvrir avec l or en tête les cherry
on va terminer en beauté avec une cabine
de l'amour sur maxime gainey et je vous
le dis c'est le mieux servi de tous a à
encore une foire est mieux servi que moi
je sais pas ben maggiani les formules
l'odeur mais j'aurais pas dû aux j'adore
a pris sa place et toi tranquille à
aller les chiens maxime bas la nuit
billy va kiffer à vous êtes célibataire
depuis longtemps depuis très très
longtemps trop longtemps le vote coeur
ne semble plus trop battre pour cali
alors j'ai une personne à qui vous
tenait énormément derrière le rideau
quelqu'un avec qui vous avez peut-être
songer à avoir une relation une certaine
période
votre teckel banon mais je vous jure que
c'est vrai comme vous risquez de
reconnaître la voix de cette personne on
va encore modifier la voix et là je vous
jure c'est un vrai dos alors oui c'est
enfin quand on écoute
allez-y par la loi bonjour bonjour a
fait le salut salut tu n'es pas une de
mes ex non droit vous savez combien avec
de telles que human quelques-uns on se
connaît tous on se connaît du milieu
[Rires]
oui oui on se connaît du milieu donc est
ce qu'on a déjà déjeuné ensemble dîné
ensemble oui à elle est célibataire ou
pas déjà est-ce que vous êtes
célibataire ou pas d'accord allez
célibataire a fallu accroche
est ce que vous êtes journaliste oui or
est-ce qu'il ya un bisou est-ce qu
est-ce qu est-ce qui vous kiffe
oui à vous le saviez
avant si je vous dis si je vous dis
animatrice minotti lima est ce que tu es
animatrice encore actuellement
oui sur nrj12 non geroudis france 5-1 à
la regarder le web à 30000 animatrice
pense à qui je pense à charmant de
femmes très talentueuse qui s'appelle
tiga et qui présente les échappées
belles sur fait remarquer que ce soit
elle vous savez un cross etel
elles émettent des accroches pour elle
bah c'est une bonne amie laure s'est
longtemps poussé pas vu ah bah ouais
vous à mort et l'aimé bien ah oui je
sais c'est du talent à l'état brut
voilà par contre c'est de la connerie
c'est pour ça qu'on vous aime les gars
est avec nous ce soir
[Applaudissements]
non
la question fronsac et une animatrice
que je sais on en touche je suis tiga c
est formidable c'est quoi cette nouvelle
peu cool acte à faire et j'ai mis mes
cheveux en vacances là tranquille
j'adore et qui gagne maximum alors on en
est où 2,7 à verrières donc c'est connu
il y avait peut-être 6 7 ans à w9
c'était une soirée c'est ça ouais ouais
w9 w9 c'est ça et vous êtes célibataire
tous les jeux de la télé tous les deux
ouais en fait gmail aventure tous les
deux la mort oui vous a réchappé belle
tous les deux les vendredis voilà
échappé belle
oui les chéris c'est le sait pas ce
qu'est ce que vous faites ce soir tibia
et bien je suis là avec vous j'ai prévu
de passer la soirée avec vous tous mes
biens et vous qu'ils soient au fait ce
soir jeanne émission de radio à 22h eh
bien tu la lune oui grâce à son domaine
avec moi voilà tu la bad avec le liban
alors vous allez passer la saint
valentin ensemble chef
si maxime préfère jeanine on peut
peut-être
[Applaudissements]
alors j'ai pas du ciel encore j'arrête
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
excuse toi
évidemment je te l'avais dit avant je
tenais [ __ ] t'es sérieux et méthode a
ses allées sont d'animer leurs élèves
dans la barre des 1 je ne peux plus vous
supportez thunder bay je vais 10 avance
a dit pourquoi tu calcules a tellement
relou j'avais su c'est quoi vous l'avais
dit avant mais c'est le plus gros lieu
du beau jeu ne pas venir avec moi est
avec lui pas dire ça me fait rigoler
mais alors il faut en avoir organisé une
grande copie danois d'arcade ouf
jannie de beer ma chérie alors vous deux
raisons de talon cassé vous êtes cassé
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
elle est vraiment partie de la famille
mais chez vous des jeux vous allez
partir ouais bon la saint-valentin cassé
le coude
voilà donc sonné vous nous tiendrons au
courant j'espère que vous allez tous de
vous connaître et essayer de vous donner
une chance de vous aimer un acte allait
repartir tous les deux avec soccer avec
l'art s'agisse ouvert que pendant cette
soirée
voker ne vont faire plus qu'un coeur
[Applaudissements]
mais ça va super bien
enfin gros bisous bonne saint valentin à
tous merci et bah je sais que toi sera
pas de terribles mais bon on retrouve
france a invité je m'approchais
l'échappée belle c'est ce constat rica
et corps a refusé le 3 mars
surfer sac a battu jeudi 11 juin râle 2
avec pisier s'est fait payer je te
mettrai tout à côté de ton prochain mais
sa lune tiga gainey
[Applaudissements]
chez les messieurs on est pratiquement
en train de faire un prime 1 je vous le
dit bébel amg chez quelque chose comme
un crack est à côté de moi j'ai dit ok
alors benhaim votre homme idéal c'est
vous dites souvent franchement et qui
est souvent que je suis comme votre
frère mais que si vous aviez un homme
idéal ce serait moi j'ai dit ça moi
voilà déjà 10 h à la librairie familiale
le diu pas c'est vrai c'est vrai c'est
vrai si jeanine dit la vérité vous vous
croyez aux compliments comme ce à quoi
vous faites là je vous y croyez ah oui
non le croire c'est vrai c'est pour ça
que j'avais que moi j'ai toujours rêvé
d'être avec vous malheureusement je ne
peux pas vous ne pouvez pas mais ce soir
je vous le dis non non benhaim je vous
jure que c'est vrai derrière ce rideau
savez j'ai ramené je vous jure j'ai
ramené quelqu'un de ma famille si vous
aimez énormément et vous avez une soeur
qui correspond à vos âges familles d'y
ramener un mes cousins qui vous aime
énormément c'est le même que moi c'est
le même que moi
sauf que lui il est prêt à vous
accueillir au il est là ce soir
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est mon cousin et mais c'est vrai que
vous ressemblez à des oufs passé mon un
coup quoi ah ouais noir voilà oui
bisous soyez pouvoir alors il est
d'origine accents mois d'origine
mayennaise
il est comme moi d'origine pakistanaise
leader je veux tellement pakistanais
aurait dit non sa sandale n'ont pas
d'idée lui dit il et dijon support avec
tous les 2-3 sa barrette apartheid